[Applause]
[Music]
it's a new month and whether it's
getting hotter or cooler in your part of
the world the times are a-changing but
the video games keep coming and june has
a whole bunch to talk about this episode
of new releases we'll take a look at the
month overall so let's get to it first
up is a game that's actually leaving
beta for a full release Riot Games
free-to-play team shooter valor ins in
case you're not already familiar here's
the deal
two teams take turns attacking and
defending on a map and each character
has a set of unique abilities that can
totally change the flow of the round
riot says the full release will include
new modes characters maps and more when
it comes to PC on Tuesday June 2nd just
note that progress is resetting for
everyone so you betta players will have
to start from scratch the next game is
actually two and one the command &
Conquer remastered collection includes C
and C and red alert both of which let
you toggle between the original graphics
and shiny new 4k it's also got
remastered music and cinematics plus mod
support and a bunch of behind the scenes
content you'll be able to compete online
with custom lobbies and a sleek new UI
to the collection comes to PC on Friday
the fifth and here we are the last of us
part two is coming soon and we'll all be
able to finally see the next chapter of
Joel and Ellie story in case you've
missed all the news around the game you
should know that you take control of
Ellie this time the story has been
largely under wraps but you should
definitely expect a healthy dose of
stealth violent action and crafting also
a lot of the game takes place in Seattle
so that's pretty hip The Last of Us part
two finally comes to ps4 on Friday the
19th the prestige drama continues with
SpongeBob SquarePants battle for bikini
bottom rehydrated yeah I'm kidding this
is a remaster of the cult classic
platformer from 17 years ago it's got a
brand new multiplayer mode with both
co-op and competitive options Plus cut
content from the original game and if
you have a ps4 Pro or Xbox one X you can
replay the adventure
fancy 4k spongebob comes to ps4 Xbox one
PC and switch on Tuesday the 23rd I only
have one question are you ready
[Music]
June is bringing us another
action-packed cartoony game with
ninjalah eight players can throw down in
teams or in a free-for-all utilizing
their special skills to run up walls use
ninjutsu and wield a whole bunch of
ninja weapons you'll get points for
taking out your opponents plus a bonus
if you do so using your special ninja
skills ninjalah comes exclusively to
Nintendo switch on Wednesday the 24th
and it'll be free-to-play when it does
and those are some of the hottest games
launching all month long as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change
thanks for watching everyone and I'll be
back with a closer look at more Jun
games next Sunday